ils sont là à regarder il est là il est
là ils sont parce qu'il ya deux produits
phares de paquets en fait c'est lui qui
nous intéresse c'est qui lui et bien
c'est l'iphone et ce trois c'est
l'iphone et ceux de 2022 c'est une
nouvelle iphone et ce qui vient
d'arriver en le nouvel iphone est ce
intéressant parce que des gens y vient
remplacer l'ancien iphone est ce assez
logique mais surtout il fait entrer la
gamme s c'est à dire les gars de la
moins chère aujourd'hui des iphones la
gamme la plus abordable même si ça reste
un certain budget on échappe attention
c'est du premium ça coûte un peu
d'argent mais néanmoins ça fait entrer
les iphone et ce dans la 5g à 5 g arrive
ici c'est intéressant parce que l'a5 ges
démocratisons va y avoir de plus en plus
même si vous n'êtes pas connu de tous et
toutes à voir switcher sur de la 5g un
abonnement sauf forfait 5 g néanmoins ça
va arriver tout doucement que les
opérateurs les au pire les autres
projets de les opérateurs les opérateurs
ils vont finir par enlever toute la cage
et donc la santé hilal à 5 j'arrivais
elle a réussi en tout cas dans votre
iphone et son essai intéressant pourquoi
parce que enfin ça montre un line up
complet 5 g chez apple même si encore
des modèles kadji qu'on peut bien
trouver quelque part grâce à gauche bref
passons l'histoire iphone est ce on a
également une petite coque de protection
je vous la passe très rapidement ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ça et oliva matin
[Musique]
rien et moi j'aime beaucoup parce que
toujours une expérience très sympa au
niveau de l'oeil boxing chez apple
pourquoi allez-vous me demander ouais
merci d'avoir posé la question parce
qu'on fait regardez vous avez ce petit
truc là c'est pareil tout bête le à 30
me fait marrer ton truc ouais mais tout
le monde le fait pas et il ya plein où
on vient sans bétail des ciseaux a dit
voilà c'est un petit effeuillage un peu
sympa et je vous assure que ça rajoute à
expérience alors une fois que c'est fait
c'est fait c'est fini on peut y aller
alors hop là alors vous avez vu déjà la
finesse ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que sur cet iphone et ce comme sur les
iphone qui connote puis cote de 1 en
deux ans deux ans il n'y a plus de bugs
de charge donc si vous voulez un bloc de
charges il faut aller l'acheter
directement chez apple ou dans toutes
les bonnes crémeries avec un chargeur
compatible si ce n'est un chargeur
d'apple n'allait pas chez les trucs chip
ça je vous ai déjà expliqué parce que ça
abîme votre smartphone mais ici ça
permet de gagner en volume dans votre
boîte c'est un peu plus peu plus cool et
puis le deuxième point qui est
intéressant aussi effectivement là est
bien c'est que nous gagnions packages on
en fait un petit peu moins d'un point de
vue écologique s'intéresse en rien le
truc qui arrivait aussi cette année
souvenez vous je voulais dit quand je
lui dis en début d'année sur d'autres
smartphones de marque et bien en fait
l'état français à changer un peu de le
dire actif quant aux écouteurs qu'on
retrouvait obligatoirement donc quand on
a acheté aujourd'hui enfin quant au losc
il ya quelques mois l'iphone on avait
cette banque a mené à une espèce de sur
boîte dans lequel on retrouvait des
écouteurs filaires pour brancher dans
votre iphone aujourd'hui la loi
française ne l'obligent plus dont vous
avez le packaging que vous avez dans le
monde entier c'est à dire juste votre
iphone à l'intérieur et voilà et moi
j'ai une version product red parce qu'il
existe un téléphone dont trois couleurs
vous avez noir ou appeler le midnight
version d'essai minuit ses couleurs noir
vous avez également un lumière stellaire
c'est plus clair c'est plus blanc c'est
plus lumineux plus tu es l'appui le
producteur a de la productrice et en
partenariat que l'association raid aux
états unis pour venir lutter contre le
vih donc si vous achetez celui là
normalement il ya une partie des fonds
qui reversait directement à la lutte
contre le vih alors on va y aller à la
démo ici y'a rien de passe-passe pour
faire de la magie ce matin là vous avez
votre iphone que vous preniez et plats
qu'on va
voilà j'espère bien alors comme vous le
voyez l'intérieur il n'y a plus grand
chose c'était là vous avez votre cas
pour vidal recharger si vous avez un pc
vous avez déjà un bloc de charge apple
vous avez qu à 35 me mettre dedans et
puis là vous avez quelques petites infos
voilà mais c'est tout c'est simple
aujourd'hui voyez les zones boxing ça
dure plus des heures alors ce qu'on va
faire tout de suite c'est vous
m'accordez 30 secondes je prends je
l'allumé on le démarre ensemble et comme
ça je vous préfère un tour complet du
propriétaire et on va regarder ce qu'ils
racontent parce qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes
iphone configurer garder voilà ce qui
est super c'est qu'en fait je peux faire
un transfert très facilement de mon
autre iphone vers cet iphone l'ice
extrêmement rapide et donc où ça marche
bien le seul truc c'est que là ils en
train d'installer les applications
directement ou via le wi fi via icloud
donc il lui faut un petit peu de temps
mais je retrouve ma configuration
initiale que j'ai sur mon iphone 13
promax et ça c'est juste très pratique
donc ça c'est cool donc voilà donc sa
taille fine qu'est ce qu'il raconte
alors premier truc ça vous aura pas
échappé c'est le designer si vous
intéressez un petit pot iphone aux
actualités d'apple vous savez que
l'iphone est ce et bien c'est un iphone
un peu atypique parce qu'ils gardent ce
vieux look qu'on avait sur les iphone
jusqu'à l'iphone 8 c'est à dire on a
sept grandes bordure en haut et en bas
on a ici touch heidi et leur bon il ya
des gens qui vont aimer qui vont pas
aimer qui on veut dire c'est quoi ce
truc là mais ça vous permet d'avoir un
iphone pour beaucoup moins cher c'est
vrai que quand on compare à des fans 13
pro mac c'est à dire quand même
aujourd'hui ce qu'il sait de plus grand
chez apple versus qui sont aujourd'hui
de plus petits ça reste quand même assez
dingue alors après le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que si vous aimez le
line up des iphone 13 vous prenez un
iphone 13 min va vous allez garder
l'encoche le même look and feel que vous
avez sur les iphone tres tres promax les
gros mais cela sera plus petit on vous
aurez plus d'écran mais vous toucherez
plus cher ici l'idée c'est qu'il est mon
coup moins cher et le tarif zèle alors
vous êtes 3 confie qu'en faites vous une
confie 64 giga de stockage 128 go de
stockage et 256 go de stockage alors je
vous le dis parce que le 64 et pas très
cher a enfin passé cher ça reste
beaucoup d'argent mais par rapport à
apple c'est pas très cher on est à 5 129
euros c'est bien on est un peu au dessus
des 500 euros mais je vous recommande
pas de 64 go de stockage parce que en
règle générale on va souvent de manquer
un petit peu et vous n'avez pas pouvoir
stocker a des tonnes de photos des
tonnes de vidéos stockées des tonnes de
musique et des tonnes de jeux donc
arrivera un moment ça coincera ça ira
plus que je vous recommande c'est le
128e sans utiliser
579 euros ici ça me paraît être le très
bon compromis alors on rajoute 50 euros
par rapport à la confirmation de cas
déjà de stockage mais on a un truc il
sera beaucoup plus durable dans le temps
au niveau de nos capacités de stockage
et puis il ya une version 256 qui a tout
de suite beaucoup plus cher ils le
vendent cher le stockage chez apple
quasiment 700 euros 699 là je suis pas
convoqué parce que je trouvais trop cher
par rapport à ce qu'on peut trouver si
vous me trouvez par exemple un iphone 12
min de l'année dernière ça me paraîtrait
tout de suite il ya un truc qui marchera
pas néanmoins l'accord fixant à 28 c
'est que jamais recommandé et que je
trouve intéressante en terme de prix
alors après il faut aimer un
effectivement cet esprit là tout en
sachant qu'ici vous avez un écran liquid
retina c'est du lcd 1 en internat de 4,7
pouces avec une résolution hd ça c'est
pas nouveau on connaissait déjà les
iphone précédents nouveau les iphone et
ce résolution hd néanmoins ici apple
maîtrise vraiment bien on se rend pas
compte que ces nuages défense a plutôt
intéressant alors à voir on regardera je
vais le tester ultérieurement donc
abonnez-vous comme ça vous serez quand
le test arrivera puis actionnez la
cloche vous serez notifié et vous saurez
tout je trouve intéressant plutôt plutôt
cool comme ça sur le papier c'est du
1334 par 750 pixels on a technology à
trous tonnes on a une gamme de couleurs
p3 et on a une luminosité max à 625 nice
bon vous voyez là il est au tac os c'est
pas l'iphone qui sera le plus lumineux
si vous avez le soleil qui va taper le
sur open journée mais bon voilà on est
aussi un tarif un peu moins cher et
apple a fait des concessions par rapport
à ça je n'ai plus habitué à voir des six
petits claviers voyez mai enfin pas
clavier c'était juste un petit écran il
touche plus petit mais ça fonctionne
alors regardez on va se mettre un truc
et on va écouter voir ce que ça raconte
qu'on veut le dews
votre vie numérique
[Applaudissements]
ça sature un peu retour de la pause ont
vu leurs alertes c'est moins bon que les
iphone 13 ça me paraît aussi logique
mais on a quand même des haut parleurs
stéréo dans le gros douce on vient de là
mais ça c'est normal et une fois de plus
on est à 5 cents et quelques grosses à
179 euros soit un conflit qui
m'intéressent moins 128 donc ça ne
paraît pas des collants et ça ça me
convient et je me retrouve hockey après
le truc c'est vrai que quand je regarde
visuellement jeu tellement habituel
iphone 13 promax que on a une vraie
différence de couleur même la regarder
ce passionné vous en rendre compte entre
ce que j'ai ici la voyez au niveau de
mes dégradé de couleurs toute cette
partie là là le grisé et le bleu là là
là j'ai une vraie différence au niveau
des icônes je me rends compte aussi ce
moment que ça fait il ya un côté relief
en moi mais bon maintenant que j'avais
tous les deux côtes à coke je suis un
peu moins sûre du truc quoi non non
c'est peut être mon ami qui déconne
c'est mon heure du matin parce qu'à
chanter le matin donc s'associer monoï
du matin qui est conne mais non sans mal
samba samba samba samba samba ok alors
en continu regarder en termes de
performance aussi raconte iphone c'est
intéressant parce que vous avez la puce
à 15 bionics exactement la même puce que
vous avez dans un gros truc là dans
l'iphone 13 promax ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'apple quand ils vous
sortent des smartphones même si on va
avoir une résolution hd même si on a
plutôt ancien look and feel même si on a
taillé dit il ya des gens qui adorent
touch a dit donc c'est encore c'est pas
le truc eh bien vous avez la même
performance la même puce que dans
l'iphone ne plus haut de gamme ils n'ont
pas fait de compromis là-dessus parce
que de toute façon ce qu'on vient
chercher ici c'est de la performance en
eau que ça marche donc sa tartine la
puce à 15 bionique elle marche vachement
bien et c'est plus ça les interactions
de sur plein de choses à vous dire que
j'ai un iphone qui fluide ça va ça
marche bien c'est rapide ouais mais il
n'ya pas que ça parce qu'en fait le truc
qui va être vachement intéressant c'est
de se dire ok mon iphone est fluide mais
ça va au delà de ça quels sont les
usages alors il ya effectivement le
gaming d'améliorer ce qu'on va venir
jouer beaucoup sur un écran de 4,7
pouces comme ça je pense qu'on peut le
faire mais après le tout qu'y va être
intéressant si la capacité de calcul et
notamment au niveau de la photo est ce
que vous allez retrouver exactement le
même savait ce qu'on appelle la fpi seul
email signal processor c'est le
processeur d'image que vous avez dans
votre puce c'est la même que vous êtes
dans un iphone 13 pro mac coûte beaucoup
plus cher par rapport à l'iphone là qui
coûte 500 et quelques euros donc ça
c'est vachement cool alors pour autant
on n'a pas exact la même chose au niveau
de la photo même si on a un capteur de
12 mégapixels mais je vous donne dans
quelques instants mais ça veut dire
qu'au terme de traitement vous aurez la
même chose le drive engine qui est là en
plus donc c'est toute la question
intelligence artificielle tout la
photographie computationnelle que vous
allez retrouver qui va venir optimiser
vos photos il n'y a pas de compromis qui
est fait ici au niveau de la performance
donc on retrouve un truc qui va vraiment
bien marché donc ça c'est cool alors
après l'autre truc est très très fort
chez apple c'est que vous voyez ça par
exemple on est sur un iphone qui est pas
très gros donc vous dirai en batterie là
vous n'avez pas dû 5 millions période je
me dis tout de suite vous avez quoi vu
l'épaisseur du smartphone si vous avez
dû 2008 100 millions terreur vous êtes
plutôt contents alors je vous dis ça
chez apple il communique pas sur les
specs il vous le disent pas ça donc on
doit pas avoir une très très grosse
batterie mais celle-là on y sont un
malin et là où ils sont forts comme ils
maîtrisaient la chaîne apple même si
c'est pas qu'ils fabriquent tous un même
s'ils ont des partenaires mais comme il
maîtrise la chaîne perd quasiment de a à
z au niveau du software au niveau du
hardware même s'il ya des partenaires
qui vont venir aggraver les puces et
compagnie eh bien il sur optimist haut
ce qui fait qu'avec une batterie aller
je veux dire un peu au pif un jeu ne
doit mouiller comme ça 2800 2500
millions terreur vous allez avoir de
très belle autonomie le logiciel c'est
le matos même s'ils sont des partenaires
dont qu'ils alignent les planètes vous
permet sortir des smartphones
extrêmement fin plutôt compact et qui je
pense vont être bons en autonomie je
pense qu'on regardera ça lors du test
mais c'est déjà ce qu'on avait sur les
générations précédentes c'est ça qui est
extrêmement mal hein parce qu'il ya
plein de personnes qui n'aiment pas ces
gros format la voyez c'est énorme iphone
vous préférez un plus petit iphone je le
comprends parfaitement dans une poche
dans un sac dans ce que vous voulez
savoir quels vachement moins de place
c'est beaucoup moins épais c'est
vraiment significatif parce que c'est
juste énorme à la différence que vous
avez entre ses iphone alors après on en
a forcément plus sur l'iphone 13 promax
en plus c'est très très gros modèles
mais le
la différence elle est juste monstrueuse
donc moi je comprends vraiment qu'on
vienne et mais ce format là parce qu'il
est compact il est pratique il est bien
dans une poche il est cool et puis il ya
plein de gens qui s'en fichent
honnêtement d'avoir des très grands
écrans avec un dédale de dingue comme ça
ça fonctionne tout en sachant tout ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'en fait ils
ont gardé la même techno nouveau du dos
il savait un dos en verre alors vous
avez le châssis en aluminium vous avez
dos en verre ce qui vous permet d'avoir
de la recharge en induction notamment
avec max life donc ça c'est cool vous
pouvez prendre les mêmes blocs de
charges que iphone 13 process pro mac
n'y a pas de souci au niveau du software
pareil c'est la même chose n'y a pas de
compromis c'est à ios 15 à plat qu'on va
venir utiliser ici et puis après vous
l'avez vu vous avez une seule optique à
l'arrière alors là c'est pas la même
taille c'est d'ailleurs extrêmement
bluffant de les mettre côte à côte j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un iphone 6 sv
reçues sur iphone 13 promax pour autant
pour autant pour autant vous avez bien
un capteur de 12 mégapixels à
l'intérieur alors la différence que vous
allez avoir ce niveau de l'ouverture
vous n'êtes pas une ouverture de f 1.6
comme vous avez six en grand-angle de
l'iphone 13 ou l'iphone 13 pro ou de
l'iphone 4s pronax ou l'iphone 13 min
ici vous avez une ouverture af 1.9 bon
ok néanmoins vous avez toutes les techno
derrière vous avez le smart hdr cadre
vous avez le diffuseur vous avez tout la
photographie computationnelle dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure avec de
l'intelligence artificielle donc là
dessus et aussi obsolescent aucun
problème à l'avant ça va être un peu
différent l'histoire vous avez une
caméra de celle ci a gardé de cette méga
pixels coucou les petits lapins elle est
cachée jusqu'ici donc ça on va regarder
aussi le résultat de quelques instants
et sera que trois petites photos vidéos
on va regarder si c'est intéressant donc
ça c'est plutôt bon je peux y accèdent
dingo parce que cela reste bien en
dessous mais voilà ils ont baissé le
prix c'est apple c'est comme ça et
pouvait venir un film et faire de la
vidéo jusqu'en le 4k à plat regardez-la
720p hd hd parce que faire de la 4k à 60
images par seconde voyez c'est écrit
juste ici noir sur blanc enfin c'est
plutôt grise au gris blanc sandwiches et
autres trucs qui intéresse ans comme
c'est au point de vue logiciel ils ont
gardé ce qu'on appellera les style
photographique bon ça je vous laisse
regarder je vous l'avais déjà présenté
avec l'iphone 13 et puis vous allez tout
le reste qui va bien du wifi 6 du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé pour un
peu le paye vous avez une carte nadeau
sim est ici la deuxième c'est là ici
mains ok il faut votre opérateur
supporte la estime si vous voulez double
carte sim en fait et puis vous avez un
smartphone qui est certifié résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière ip67 donc voilà
pour la partie config haut niveau cet
iphone et ça d'iphone qui est dispo dès
maintenant d'ailleurs si vous intéresse
vous met le prix en bas par la
description je vous montre rapidement
quelques photos que j'ai prises dans la
rue avec cet iphone alors attention ici
on n'a qu'un capteur donc on va pas bien
souvent parce qu'on peut avec un zoom
numérique jusqu'à x 5 mais on va éviter
on reviendra de façon un peu plus
complète lors du têt ça c'est vraiment
pour avoir une première vision un peu
dans semble donc il ya uniquement des
photos sympas du trader on tangue pas de
zoom gré du touret son capteur principal
ça effectivement regard des ressources
et une photo j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
de plus lissée sur l'écriture théâtrale
à tes souhaits il a plu alors fait de
voir là c'est un bout de vitrine mais il
ya des refaire une petite faute aussi
comme ça
ça me semble correct sa première photo
de mode portrait voyez ça ben voilà
c'est ça fonctionne bien ça des tours
bien assis là il a eu un petit peu de
mal voyez sur la main là il a considéré
un peu comme étant de l'arrière-plan
donc ça c'est un peu moins bon je sais
pas ce qui lui est arrivé là donc on peu
plus de mal là dessus et sur une autre
photo un peu plus loin voyez il l'a
récupéré donc je sais pas ce que j'avais
bouger je sais pas ce qui s'était passé
là dessus un peu de verdure parisienne
ok c'est pas le truc le plus dingue que
j'ai vu me
il faut creuser un peu l'histoire un
petit bout de terrasse aussi à la volée
c'est vraiment vite fait donc on n'a pas
été chercher les photos et plus d'1 go
du monde là au niveau du ciel à ça
fonctionne bien on a bien le ciel les
nuages on a su s'emparer correct qu'on a
ici là plutôt bien géré l'appareil a
gardé on vient chercher on a bien les
feuilles le d'état et on voit le ciel
derrière
et là ici appareils ça me semblait pas
trop mal maintenant il faut tester dans
d'autres conditions pour voir ce que ça
raconte comme ça le boulot a l'air
d'être faite il faut creuser il faut
aller plus loin il faut regarder il ya
des choses qui me plaisent qui sont un
peu un peu moins mais voilà il faut
avancer et on verra ça lors du test
alors caméra de celle fille appât de
stable et on peut filmer uniquement je
suis en hd à 30 images par seconde en
voyons on est un peu de dignité quand
même sur l'histoire donc là c'est pas
forcément la bonne caméra qu'il faudra
moir en tout cas ici ça c'est pour la
vie regardez à l'arrière j'ai un petit 4
qu'à 30
c'est mieux alors quand je vois comme ça
moi ça bouge un petit peu suppression de
la stable mais d'un autre côté je pense
que derrière avec la lgo ça va venir le
compenser et corrigé donc voilà c'est
vraiment histoire de commencer à
regarder un petit peu et de voir ce
qu'on est capable de faire avec ce
smartphone à la main comme ça on
poussera le test un peu plus mais en
tout cas comme ça bon faut voir voilà
pour ce nouvel iphone et ce alors on va
se regarder le test des sites quelques
jours donc venez vous abonner si ce
n'est pas le cas que surtout opposé mois
toutes vos questions en bas on
commentaires dites moi ce que vous en
pensez c'est des questions
interrogations suggestions je regarderai
tout ça pour vous apporter le maximum de
réponse dans la vidéo test voilà d'ici
là je vous embrasse pour le soin de vous
et beaucoup 2015
[Musique]